this next story is absolutely
fascinating um many of you might
remember the name sydney powell
sydney powell is this kooky lawyer
who was you know she was working with
trump on the election fraud claims and
then when she got too cartoonish she was
no longer working with trump per the
white house but then she was seen at the
white house and she filed a bunch of
these bogus uh uh court uh uh legal
complaints all of which were thrown out
she is now admitting
maybe all that stuff she was saying
about the election was not true now i
think we really have to approach this
with a skeptical eye maybe even a
cynical perspective
has she really changed her mind or is
she saying this because she is now in
such jeopardy
because of the things that she did
there's a very interesting vice news
article titled sydney powell finally
admits
that perhaps the kraken is not real
but it also says facing disbarment and
several billion dollar lawsuits the
pro-trump lawyer is kind of changing her
story and i think we have to consider
uh the context here the admission from
powell came in a brief filed monday to
the u.s court of appeal for the sixth
district it was signed by powell and
fellow lawyer howard kleinhendler filed
on behalf of several other kraken
lawyers though notably not pro-trump
lawyer lynn wood who's also a party
um back in august you might remember and
we covered this at the time district
court judge linda parker eviscerated
powell and her uh
team saying the lawsuit represents a
historic and profound abuse of the
judicial process and it does it's one
thing to take on the charge of
vindicating rights associated with an
allegedly fraudulent election it is
another to take on the charge of
deceiving a federal court and the
american people into believing rights
were infringed without regard to whether
any laws or rights were in fact violated
and that is what happened here
now um
powell this is fascinating
powell has argued at the time
she was under no obligation to
thoroughly research the claims that she
made about voter fraud in the lawsuit
she sort of made the case at the time
listen people came to me and they said
this is what happened
and it's not up to me to independently
verify that that's what the case is i'm
just the lawyer here which the judge
does not agree with and it makes
absolutely no sense
um
in this week's filing powell and
kleinhandler casually admit
everything they had been saying may not
actually be true
but because lots of people were saying
it at the time they decided to include
it quote millions of americans believe
the central contentions of the complaint
to be true
and perhaps they are
admitting she's no longer actually
confident
about the veracity of those claims now
i think it's important to ask the
question
does she believe all of these wacky
election claims are true but she's
backing off because of the legal
problems that she's now happening she's
now having
did she never believe the claims were
true or did she believe them and she has
since changed her mind
legally speaking i don't know that it
makes a difference
um as a reminder
here are some of the wacky things that
this woman said
the amount of evidence that this
election was completely fraudulent and
that joe biden is a fraudulent president
is beyond overwhelming now understand
that
if we are to believe her current
statement
what she meant when she said that was
the people i'm working with told me this
but i don't really know it to be true
that's what she now says listen we were
told these things we didn't
independently confirm them here's
another sydney powell clip so
i don't know where to go next because
this is like something out of a movie so
the department of defense let's review
yeah 2006 a patent coming from the
department of defense that allows for
algorithm that can flip and change votes
the patent was transferred to i love the
reference to an algorithm
it's an algorithm
it can predetermine that algorithm can
predetermine the outcome of an election
it's specifically to
uh
create a predetermined outcome okay so
maybe she believed that to be true at
the time or again maybe that's just what
some of the people she was working with
told her um here's another one about a
secret server what i think really has to
be
discovered is that there is a secret
server that all the votes go to where
they manipulate the heck out of it now
did she believe that at the time or was
that also just something people were
telling her and here's one last one with
this wacky guy stu peters
that for at least 20 years now
somebody other than the voters of the
united states of america has been
determining
certain elections and this year if not
prior years it happened to be the
presidency of the united states of
america now did she believe that at the
time
or again was it just we were told that
stuff and we didn't investigate it so
sydney powell now saying ah we don't
really know that any of that stuff was
true it's just what we were told just
what we were told by plaintiffs uh she's
really uh potentially in trouble here
and i think that's all that's going on
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at d pacman
if you or someone you know is into
science astronomy space this is for you
our sponsor under lucky stars creates
beautiful personalized star maps
showing the unique position of the stars
in the sky
at the place and time chosen by you
under lucky stars is a great way to
remember an important moment someone's
birthday wedding day your engagement you
give them a time and a location that you
want to commemorate they show you
exactly how the stars and constellations
looked in a spectacular super high
quality print to completely personalized
gift experience you can customize it
into a ton of designs you can read on
their website how all the star maps are
scientifically accurate
this is the one i got showing the time
of my birth in buenos aires argentina
the quality of the material and the
print they're fantastic i was really
impressed and i love that they support
the international dark sky association
to fight against light pollution under
lucky stars is perfect for valentine's
day and right now they're giving my
viewers 10
off when you click the link below and
enter the code d pacman